[Music]
okay so the punisher season two I don't
even know where to begin with this one
let me just say I was a huge fan of
Punisher season one it had its flaws but
I had so much heart to it and passion
and made me feel things I've never felt
another shows and season two was a
dumpster fire let me address the biggest
complaint so far this season with jigsaw
aka Billy Russo and it's not with the
acting benbarnes is incredible again but
the scars good lord those scars they
actually symbolize the whole season for
me they're toned down there to clean and
they're safe and that was your big hint
to how this season was gonna go instead
of taking the show up a notch
they took this show down a couple of
notches and what really summed up this
season for me and made me laugh out loud
was when Billy went to see Curtis took
his mask off and his complaining at what
happened to him
and he's like look what happened to my
face I started crying laughing at how
unaffected this was because the scars
were not representative of what Frank
Castle did to him last season and that's
why it's so important the actor the crew
can downplay this a lot saying the
makeup was fine but it wasn't it really
was super important for a role like this
that's like having to face from Batman
just having little burn marks I mean
this looked like a few razor cuts it
just looks like Billy Russo had a bad
razor come on he looked too handsome
still we're supposed to buy that he's
really upset about his face and other
people are disgusted by him Frank looked
way worse with his scars this season
from just fights he gets in day by day
and on top of that the masks he has
that's his little art project from his
therapist was really cheesy and did not
explain well enough why he drew what he
drew it was silly and staying on this
Billy story him and this therapist he
was with who was crazy as well their
relationship was the epitome of horrible
television there was waste too much
scenes of them chatting
in the bed together and then him abusing
her and then them making out they were
trying to do like a Joker Harley Quinn
thing here and it wasn't working and it
was so much of this and that is where
during the season
I'd use every strength in me to keep
watching and push through those scenes
because it was torture and with Billy
Russo I think it was a good idea smart
idea to try to do the thing where he's
forgotten his memory and what exactly
happened to him but they didn't execute
it well they need to move it quicker of
him figuring out what happened to him
who he thought wronged him and it was
way too slow and it took away for
moments that should have been bigger
with him being so confused way too late
in the game and it really affected when
he saw Frank at the end what a letdown
of an end that was with Frank just
shooting him twice in the stomach they
didn't have this big showdown which was
set up here and he still seemed confused
at the end Billy just a mess here where
was the payoff like we had in season one
they built up so much here with this
rivalry of him and Billy and what he did
to his family to just have two shots in
the chest I mean he ripped this guy's
face apart come on I wanted to see this
addressed and so now going to the
Punisher storyline with Frank Castle
this whole opening sequence with him
meeting this new girl Amy also known as
Rachel felt like they were trying to
pull off a Logan thing here but it
wasn't working and this girl Amy is
really annoying off the bat she's
frustratingly an idiot and she keeps
running from place to place not
listening to Frank not giving him any
information so it makes her so unlikable
because you're like come on just say
something help Frank he's helping you he
just saved your life and just keeps
repeating in that course so it's adding
that teen character that's frustratingly
stupid that never helps a show and so
many shows keep repeating this I don't
know when no learn and and it's just a
trap and with Frank's love interest I
liked at the beginning here the
bartender she gets hurt but then where
does she go that's it we never see her
again
I thought she appeared the end at least
nothing totally forgotten about very
weird and again with this Amy Rachel
girl throughout there's not an ounce of
depth here to her characters there's no
trauma no gratitude no Hugh
just a moody team and it made me really
miss micro from season one here his
comic relief was great and he had such
good chemistry with Frank and this made
me appreciate that much more because
this just did not work with Rachel as a
second billing and it ended up becoming
just a bunch of side characters telling
Frank not to kill anymore which we've
seen already done so much and it
actually brought down his character a
bit here
Punisher fans want the brutal death they
want the killing he got a feed your your
target demographic a bit here and they
were kind of doing them a distance the
season and it felt like any other
superhero show with a not killing that's
what makes Punisher so special and if
you're gonna have that theme keep going
here we see it in every other show
especially in this Marvel Universe so
come on you're going to piss off your
audience for Punisher fans and then
Madani again I really like the actress
here I think she's great but the
character is just poorly written and to
top off her terrible story line when she
battled this therapist and they went at
it how did she get that beat up from a
therapist I mean she's a homeland
security agent and we've seen her
trained in combat this was absolutely
ridiculous and Ironfist levels bad like
how was no one on set filming that being
like what are we doing here there needs
to be a voice of reason in moments like
this because I know sometimes you don't
see till in the cutting room how bad
something might come out but when you're
there you've got a sense this is not
plausible and then this villain john
pilgrim here he's your cliche russian
villain and another cliche of just
someone quoting Bible verses to quote
them this has been so overdone and he
just was so bland and boring and very
confusing motors in the beginning he got
more depth to his character towards the
end but I still just did not care that
much because he just wasn't cool and a
big plot hole that really fresh trimming
the season was with John pilgrim and the
Punisher in the woods when Madonna is
hovering over in the homeland security
helicopter she's got the lights on them
they're caught dead in their tracks and
somehow he gets away also with Frank
Castle near him so they both just let
him go and even if they did lose him
Frank would be furious in that moment
afterwards wanting to find him but that
didn't happen so it was a character
consistency big pothole wasn't addressed
what are we doing here that's amateur
filmmaking and amateur writing and a
scene I also saw other people
complaining about was the Punisher not
killing that pedophile I can totally
understand the frustration of fans here
because against the Punisher and he's
killed pedophiles before without
hesitation but I also understand that
scene they got a complicated character a
little bit so I get it but they didn't
need to ram down the not killing thing
down our throats and the whole jigsaw
rounding up these hooligans here it was
so ridiculous and stupid and just not
interesting so she's gonna talk about
robbing a bank like come ah so this
whole season to me was so upsetting here
cuz the actors here are really good Jon
Bernthal is an amazing Punisher and Ben
Barnes is a great actor but just wasted
on a poor script and bad makeup design
this season played scared where season 1
was fearless that alone upsets me I felt
betrayed that whole scene or momentum
that was built up and they had in that
tone they had was completely shut down
from the beginning here season 1 struck
a powerful emotional chord it really did
the PTSD thing well and it made you
always focus on Frank's mindset where he
was actually kind of a sideshow and
toned him down and this is just really
disappointing it's the last we see of
him and this show but the positive of
the season the action was still pretty
good wasn't as good as season 1 wasn't
as brutal but I really liked the gym
sequence I like the bar sequence and the
ending scene where he's shooting up with
two machine guns side-by-side these two
gangs that takes place three months
later that was really awesome and that's
what people wanted this season so
hopefully there's a season three to tell
that story they're teasing it almost
felt like them admitting like oh yeah we
should have done this gotcha
so overall I'm giving this season a four
which is really low out of 10 I hate
doing that but it really upset me and it
was really really hard to watch that's
the key here I didn't care about
anything going on the new characters
added didn't help at all they only made
it worse
and jigsaw was an absolute
and really the biggest emotional thing
that ruined this all for me was the
visual of jigsaws makeup I don't care
what anyone says I know we had the
trauma in his head but there's no excuse
for that again it's like having to face
not be to face please let me know what
you thought this season down below I'm
really interested to hear what you guys
have to say on this I read every comment
they try to respond to as many as I can
please subscribe so don't miss one of my
reviews I review a bunch of TV shows I
do movie reviews as well and I interview
actors and actresses please follow me at
Steve Harley 1 on Twitter and Instagram
for more of me and I'll see you next
time